there's the graphic that shook things up
considerably yesterday from zach wilson
above trevor lawrence for number one to
kellen maughan from texas a m above
justin fields and trey lance
chris even shireen williams the most
devoted aggie on the planet thought you
were smoking something other than
tobacco when you put kel and man ahead
of justin fields and trey land well you
know listen this is why you know nbc
pays me money and this is this is what i
do okay and and shireen no i'm not
smoking anything i've been on a very
long detox session here and i'm quite
sick of it actually so you know
but honestly you know
i didn't go in this i don't go in this
with preconceived notions or let me do
this
you know as i told you yesterday you
know my dad had put monde on my radar a
little bit during the year when i dove
into the doing the quarterback stuff you
know i started to crack through he kept
going like have you watched the mankind
have you watched the mon kid and i got
into it and you know what i would say to
shireen is well shireen what's there not
to like i mean it's an it's an
unbelievable arm the accuracy is off the
charts he throws into tight windows he
can throw under pressure he can do
everything i i he understands how to
like not make big mistakes it's one of
the cleaner tapes of all these guys i
mean it's it is noticeably cleaner than
ohio state you know justin fields or
trey lance or any of that it's there's
to me a little bit of a notch there now
ohio state is really good it's
superstars all over the field okay and
that can make things look sexy and all
that too and ryan day is a hell of an
offensive coordinator and people are
open a lot too but man i'm not going to
back down from this calendar thing it's
real the mvp of the senior bowl
um
and
he he he was one of the pleasant
surprises of this process so i'm i'm not
backing down from calamond i really love
it
question from a dolphins fan d gone
draft should the dolphins take one of
your top quarterbacks with the third
selection in the draft because it sounds
like there's still going to be
someone pretty special available after
the first two guys go it's it's going to
be a very tough decision there's no
doubt
you know my first thing would be if zack
wilson's there
then yes
i would go with him again i think he's
that special to where you just go whoa
you know again i don't throw far rogers
mahomes that type of player around to
like people every year i don't do that
you know this guy's got that aspect to
him so from that standpoint without a
doubt you know do i think mac jones is
better than tua coming out i do there's
no doubt about it in my opinion mac
jones has got a lot of special special
special attributes he really does he is
a dead eye thrower i mean every ball is
on the money he can throw under pressure
he's got plenty of arm power it's better
than what people are giving him credit
for
um
and the movement and stuff he can do
there is special too so as one of those
three
yeah i mean i i would think about it i
would think about it but of course
that's going to come down to their
evaluation and what they think about
this process too and of course if desean
watson becomes available maybe they
decide to do that as well
boy that would be something if the
dolphins a year after taking alabama
quarterback tuatanga right would take
alabama quarterback mack jones
magazine's question oh sorry i'm just
going to say one thing
it is one of the more like i said
yesterday it's joe burrowish as far as
his ability to read the field and
dissect and pull the trigger almost just
seamlessly without your like wait how
did he even evaluate it that quick and
make that throw just flipping across the
field like that and you know
he played an all-sec schedule this year
and look at this
i mean this is one of the greater
schedules he played anybody has ever
played in the history of college
football and he dominated and he didn't
have four first-round receivers on his
team he only had one for the most of the
year that was it
and i i really still i'm gonna go back
to the the way
he he's kind of looks like a nerd
and he doesn't look cool in his uniform
and i think that's really hurt the hype
thing i hear it from everybody i really
think that's hurt his hype in this whole
situation
sorry where would you put tua
in this group of 2021 quarterbacks where
would he land in your top six oh
i like the top four better than i like
tua
so it he probably he'd probably be you
know justin fields and trey lance
are there's you're gonna play a
different style of football in my
opinion when you first get them you are
they're they're a little too unpolished
as pure throwers and pocket passers at
this point so
like his talent and ceiling is not as
high as a justin fields or a trey lance
but
tua brings a lot of good things to the
table and i don't want to disrespect
that and i think if i was to inject him
into that that class i'd probably have
him five
wow well that may tell you what you
think the dolphins ultimately need to do
how about the eagles with the sixth
overall pick can you compare and this is
a question from erilano tan can you
compare jalen hurts
to the guys that you have on your board
of six top quarterbacks well he'd he'd
be similar to maybe a trey lance but i
think trey lance's throwing is more
special than jalen hurts now he didn't
get to play at oklahoma and get the
coaching of alabama and do those things
so you know that was a huge thing for
jalen hurts i mean jalen hurts left
alabama because
he wasn't gonna play i mean he his
throwing was less than
he got to go to the big 12 and play out
a team that was clearly the best team in
the big 12. and he got to throw the ball
50 times a game and that really helped
his career so trey lance would be that
guy i think trey lance is actually
faster than jalen hurts and i think trey
lance
you know mechanically
has less issues than jalen hurts trey
lance could be a special special thrower
he can it's just that it's lack of games
mike and there's so many games where i
mean he only throws the ball like 15
times just 20 20 it's 20 20 or 2019 when
he played last and you're throwing the
ball 15 18 times you know that that's
that's odd and that would scare me just
a little bit so again i think you'd have
to play a certain way but i think his
potential
and his ability to throw the football is
greater than jalen hurts
look at that no losses yeah 19 and no
interceptions 28 touchdowns no
interceptions you rarely see that
usually there's one or two
um
and and here's the challenge for the
eagles because we know how they value
the quarterback position specifically
the backup quarterback position a top 15
spot on the entire roster with carson
wentz being traded as of march 17 they
need someone else to step in and get the
job done
do you
get two guys with similar styles
so they're interchangeable and you got
one playbook or do you have a change of
pace guy that's that's
part of part of the conundrum because
there's value in being able to switch
from right-handed to southpaw whenever
you feel like it but it's easier for
your offense if the number two
quarterback whoever it is has the same
playing style as the starter because
then it's one playbook and nothing
changes when the backup comes in i i've
the coach they hired
nick ciriani
they're they're a throwing coaching
staff they want to drop back and beat
people throwing the football siriani
came from the chargers who threw the
hell out of it and then the colts they
want to play that style of offense so
within that coaching hire
i would say no you'd want to you want a
guy that can maximize what these coaches
can bring to the table and play this
style of football and to me that's more
of the drop back pass guy if they decide
to draft a quarterback at number six
i'm trading jalen hurts i am what are
you gonna do the same thing again so the
quarterback can struggle and then
everybody goes oh we should put jalen
hurts in and then we can just screw the
whole situation up
if i'm the philadelphia eagles
i'm going and you do do the quarterback
thing
i'm going okay we're going on we're
going with this quarterback and i'm
calling the baltimore ravens and saying
hey do you need a really awesome backup
quarterback that fits your system and
jalen hurts and then hey he could
probably play some receiver and do some
things like that and but yet it goes to
what you're saying uh that would be my
take just seeing this question and
popping it off my head right now
one more real quick one before we take a
break 49ers question from at not the
police which of these quarterbacks on
your list of the top six do you think
kyle shanahan
your buddy your friend your former
college teammate and the 49ers would
like the most well i think zack wilson's
the guy that he would like the most i i
do it just that's that's the guy for
that system the movement the crazy
deliveries the power and the arm all of
those things but i also think like a mac
jones
could fit you know allah a
better version of a
kirk cousins in ways coming out of the
draft and could be that guy in that
system too right i do i think you know
coming out of the draft and everything
like that mac jones has got a is a
better thrower a better arm than kirk
cousins his size is a little bit better
and again
mac jones has this tennis background
right his feet are unreal i mean unreal
other than zach wilson he has the best
feet in the pocket to move and slide and
shuffle and do all those things within
it so those would be two guys that i
think fit the way kyle shanahan would
want to play football
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports